Das war's für heute.
The war's für heute.
Das war's für heute, heute.
Das war's für heute.
Aber wenn du aus Nose-Linux-VM da geht kein Pitch-Networking, bei einer Windows 10-VM geht alles.
Also bei den gleichen Settings sollte es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen.
Kann das sein, dass dein Linux einfach nicht versucht eine IP zu bekommen?
Kann das sein?
Also, dass das prinzipiell geht, aber du keine IP automatisch bekommst.
Was ist denn, wenn du versuchst mal von Hand eine IP dem Interface zu geben und Gateway zu setzen?
Geht das dann?
Ansonsten ist das Streamer zu diagnostizieren schwierig.
So, aber mal zum heutigen Stream.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie lange das Ganze geht.
Ich mache das vor allem hauptsächlich erstmal, dass ich selbst einen Überblick bekomme, was gibt es für neue Intel-CPUs?
Was gibt es für Mainboards dafür?
Es gibt von MSI habe ich gesehen so ein richtiges Weihnachtsbaum-Mainboard.
Das ist wirklich bunter als der Weihnachtsbaum.
Wir gucken uns das an und ich habe so ein paar Anforderungen, die ich von einem Mainboard brauche.
Und ich habe auch so ein paar Sachen, die ich halt mit dem PC machen will, wo er sich gut vereignen soll.
Deswegen müssen wir uns das Ganze jetzt mal angucken und das hätte ich eh gemacht.
Deswegen streame ich das Ganze jetzt mal, weil ich denke mal, das interessieren noch mehr Leute.
Aber ich habe kein Wasser, das ist schlimm.
Weil ich aber irgendwie so viel Lava brauche, wenn man Wasser hat zum Trinken.
Captain Sieker, ich würde dir vorschlagen, je nachdem, was du installiert hast,
nimm einen Network-Manager oder so etwas, irgendwas, wo du von Hand einen GUI hast,
wo du IP und Subnet-Mask und Gateway und DNS und so eintragen kannst.
Also was ich aktuell für einen Rechner habe, vielleicht nochmal zur Erklärung.
Aktuell habe ich einen Xeon 1032v3.
Den habe ich mir gekauft.
Kann ich nämlich zeigen, weil ich habe dazu ein Video gemacht, deswegen weiß ich das noch.
Mein neuer Rechner, was ist drin?
Das habe ich gekauft.
Von wann ist das Video?
Hier, 16. Oktober 2013 habe ich den alten Rechner gekauft.
Und ich habe auch irgendwo hier eine Anzeige, was drin war.
In dem Rechner damals, also sprich, da ist ein Xeon 1032v3 drin.
Das hat 4 x 3,3 GHz damals.
Das war Sockel 1150.
Dann habe ich 16 GB DDR3-RAM.
Den kann ich auf jeden Fall nicht verwenden.
Das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Ein 580 Watt Be Quiet-Netzteil und ein Mainboard.
Was ich davon weiter verwenden werde, ist...
Die Grafika habe ich auch nicht mehr.
Da habe ich mittlerweile 1.080 TI und hier zu SSD habe ich zusätzlich noch eine 2 TB SSD.
Aber das schreiben wir uns gleich noch mal auf.
Was ich hier von weiter verwenden werde, ist definitiv das Gehäuse.
Das ist das beste Gehäuse, das beste PC-Gehäuse, was ich je hatte.
Das ist das hier.
Was ist das hier?
Da gibt es mittlerweile schon Nachfolger für.
Gibt es eigentlich schon R6?
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Da gibt es Nachfolger, aber das sehe ich nicht ein.
Wozu sollte ich mir ein neues Gehäuse kaufen?
Das Gehäuse ist wirklich extrem geil.
Das beste Gehäuse, was ich je hatte, das ist ein bisschen breiter.
Als normalerweise.
Aber von der Verarbeitung her und allem ist das wirklich das beste Gehäuse.
Ich sehe keinen Grund, mir ein neues Gehäuse zu kaufen.
Einfach nur, weil ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe.
Das ist ja auch bescheuert irgendwo.
Wozu?
Ja, ich baue einen neuen Rechner.
Und ich wollte mir schon lange einen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Ich habe schon darauf gewartet, dass hier neue Intel-CPUs rauskommen.
Letztes Mal dachte ich noch eher AMD.
Aber nachdem ich heute die Benchmarks und das ganze Zeug gesehen habe,
tendiere ich mittlerweile wieder eher zu Intel.
Ob das jetzt die finale Zusammenstellung ist, die wir heute uns ausdenken,
das muss ich nochmal zeigen.
Aber ich will wie gesagt selbst erstmal gucken.
Also das Gehäuse habe ich zur Zeit.
Das heißt, wir schreiben uns das jetzt nochmal kurz auf.
Medicaid, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Ich habe es nur ganz kurz vorhin überflogen.
Also, schreiben wir das mal auf.
Ich mache die Schrift mal ein bisschen größer.
Neuer PC.
Also, wir haben einen Fractal.
Hier kommen wir zum Beispiel zu der Code, die Schrift hatte größer machen.
Da gab es irgendwie so eine komische Config-Datei.
Das war eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
So, kann man jetzt nämlich einfach sagen,
Editor Font Size ist 20.
Da sieht man das nämlich auch ganz gut.
Wir können auch noch ein bisschen größer machen.
24.
Also, was wir haben, ist auf jeden Fall wie gesagt noch ein Fractal Design R4.
Das behalte ich auch, weil, geiles Gehäuse, gibt es nichts zu sagen.
Das behalte ich auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, das muss ich nicht neu kaufen.
So, und das ist alt, das habe ich noch.
Das habe ich noch.
So, dann habe ich auch noch kein RGB-Mist.
Ne, ich hasse RGB-Beleuchtung.
Bei neuen Mainboards werde ich leider nicht dazu jetzt dran vorbeikommen, ja.
Weil die haben alle irgendwelche Lichter und so dran.
Mir geht es ja bei der Grafikkarte schon auf den Keks, dass die leuchtet.
Hallo Nielsen.
Übrigens Nielsen, unser Beratungsvideo müssen wir noch machen.
Ich verschaffe mir hier gerade nochmal einen Überblick.
Falls ich Mist erzähle, schreib das ruhig in den Chat rein.
Ich habe nämlich selbst noch keine Ahnung von der neuen Generation.
Mal gucken, was es so alles gibt.
Also, Infractal Design R4 habe ich noch.
Das behalte ich auch.
Meine 512 GB Samsung SSD behalte ich natürlich auch.
Und die 2 TB behalte ich natürlich auch.
Das wäre bescheuert.
Dann habe ich noch eine 6 TB WD irgendwas.
Die behalte ich natürlich auch.
Weil, warum soll ich die wegschmeißen? Das wäre ja auch total beknackt.
So, wichtig ist, dann hatte ich einen...
Dann hatte ich einen 580 Watt...
Ne, 500 was? Wo ist das?
Das hatte ich.
Das behalte ich auch.
Sehe ich nicht ein, das auszutauschen.
Und dann habe ich natürlich noch eine GTX 1080 Ti.
Die bleibt natürlich auch.
Das heißt, im Prinzip brauchen wir eigentlich nur neu.
Wir brauchen eine CPU.
Wir brauchen eine Mainboard.
Und wir brauchen eine RAM.
RAM habe ich zwar noch.
Habe ich noch 16 GB DDR3.
Aber das geht nicht.
Kann man hier...
UTF-8X.
Aber auch immer gibt es da nicht irgendein schönes...
Einen X-Mark wollen wir haben.
Genau, einen X-Mark.
Den können wir nicht mehr verwenden.
Der ist für den Arsch.
So, obwohl ich mir jetzt überhaupt nicht sicher bin,
ist der Kühler...
Das ist noch ein normaler SATA SSD Fluxig.
Beides, beides.
Ende 2018 soll schon DDR5 rauskommen, habe ich gehört.
Ja, ich denke mir da mittlerweile...
Guck mal, der Felix, was macht der hier?
PC schneller hochfahren.
Ah, okay, der macht Kingston-Kampagne.
Warum nicht, kann man machen.
Das Einzige, wo ich mir nicht sicher bin, ist...
Was mit meinem CPU-Kühler ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, vielleicht weiß der Nilsson das.
Weil der Kühler, der geht eigentlich für den Socke.
Schreiben die vielleicht auch mal irgendwo, was da alles unterstützt?
Haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Es ist ja auch für den Lüfter vollkommen unwichtig,
was der für Plattformen unterstützt.
Man muss ja schon wissen, das ist ja...
Also ich habe mal vorhin geguckt, der kann die Plattform theoretisch.
Genau, also theoretisch müsste mein alter Lüfter auch funktionieren.
Da kommt einfach ein bisschen Wärmeleit, passt drunter und gut ist.
Da muss ich aber noch mal genau gucken.
Sogar der Nilsson sagt, es würde auch funktionieren.
Da muss ich mir sicher sein, ob das wirklich passt.
Weil sonst, es gibt nichts frustrierender, wenn ich mir einen CPU-Kauf,
einen Mainboard-Kauf, RAM-Kauf alles ausgebaut habe aus dem Rechner,
alles neu eingebaut habe in das Gehäuse und dann feststelle,
der Lüfter passt nicht richtig.
Dass der Abstand und so passt, ist klar.
Das ist mir klar, dass da theoretisch auch das Mainboard passen müsste.
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie es mit Kühlleistung aussieht.
Es gab ja mal vor einer Weile das Gerücht, dass ältere Lüfter
bei Skylake-CPUs die CPU verformen würden.
Keine Ahnung, ob da jemals was dran gewesen ist, habe ich vor einer Weile gelesen.
Wahrscheinlich stimmt das nicht. Blödsinn.
Das ist ja kein Bulldozer.
Ha, Lull-AMD-Joke.
Nee, aber das...
Muss den halt schön reinigen.
Klar muss der Lüfter sauber gemacht werden vorher.
Aber das Schöne ist, dass das Gehäuse hat...
Also komm, komm, Staub rein.
Ab und zu, wenn ich den alten Rechner mal aufmache,
und was auch immer, irgendwas...
Letztes Mal habe ich die 1080Ti eingebaut.
Da ist fast null Staub drin.
Das Gehäuse ist echt geil.
Das Gehäuse ist wirklich gut.
Gucken wir mal, ob man auf YouTube...
Also das Gehäuse kann ich euch nur empfehlen.
Wenn ihr ein Gehäuse sucht...
Ich meine, ich würde mir da natürlich das Fünfer kaufen.
Ich würde mir jetzt nicht mehr das alte Gehäuse kaufen.
Aber vielleicht sieht man hier mal ein paar Bilder von dem Gehäuse.
Das ist halt echt gut.
Das ist wirklich geil.
Hast du Staubfilter drin?
Theoretisch hast du auch eine Lüftersteuerung oben,
die ich nicht brauche, weil ich keine extra Lüfter drin habe.
Hast du Staubfilter?
Kannst du hier hinten eine SSD machen,
die du dann hier vorne rausführen kannst.
Das heißt, du hast hier vorne alles frei für Festplatten.
Man kann die Festplatten, weil es schräg eingebaut ist,
auch relativ einfach wechseln.
Also fast wie ein Hotspot-Rahmen.
Fast, fast, ja.
Das ist nicht Hotspot, weil da ist halt nichts dran.
Aber das ist wirklich gut.
Ähm...
Ups.
Ich habe es mit Fenster, das Gehäuse.
So.
Aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal die neuen Sachen an.
Und zwar habe ich heute gelesen.
Einmal auf Golem und einmal auf Computerbase.
Ich glaube, die haben beide Benchmarks zu den neuen CPUs.
Und da muss ich jetzt einmal durchscrollen, wo das hier gewesen ist.
Und da sieht man, dass die neuen Intel-CPUs
gegen die schnellsten Ryzen-CPUs ziemlich gut abschneiden.
Zwar nicht im...
Wo haben wir denn hier Benchmarks?
Okay, wir müssen uns mal durchklicken, bis wir bei Benchmarks sind.
Übrigens, Computerbase ist immer eine super Seite,
wenn man sich über neue Hardware-Sachen informieren will.
Was ich nicht verstehe, ist Computerbase hat hier unten immer
so einen Dropdown.
Ach nee, hier oben ist das.
Hauptsache mal gemeckert.
Also.
Genau.
Man sieht...
Gesamtanwendung.
Also wenn man sich jetzt mal hier Cinebench anguckt,
oder Cine...
Wie spricht man das eigentlich aus?
Cinebench?
Ähm...
Das ist natürlich rein CPU in your face.
Da dürfte der Ryzen natürlich noch vorne sein.
Aber auch nicht viel.
Man muss sich mal überlegen,
der neue Intel i7 8700K in dem Fall,
der hat 6 Kerne.
Und...
Der Ryzen hat, glaube ich, 8.
Genau.
Der hat 8.
Also das heißt, in einem CPU-Benchmark,
wo es rein synthetische...
Wir testen einfach, wie schnell es geht,
parallelisierbar in your face.
Da ist klar, dass der Ryzen natürlich seine 2 Kerne mehr ausspielen kann.
Aber dafür, muss man sagen,
hält sich das jetzt ja auch in Grenzen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass der jetzt 150% schneller oder sonst was wäre,
sondern das ist nur ein bisschen.
Und wenn wir mal zu Games kommen...
Haben die überhaupt ein Gamebenchmark drinne?
Ähm...
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst im Chat?
Das Gehäuse hat null Kabelsalat.
Ähm...
Andere Seite für Games, okay.
Hatte... Hatte...
Ich habe Gamebenchmarks gesehen.
Ninson, hast du da einen?
Ich habe Gamebenchmarks gesehen,
heute auf dem iPhone im Zug.
Hatte... Hatte Golang Gamebenchmarks.
Also ich habe irgendwo gelesen,
dass in Games natürlich die Intel-CPU wieder,
ähm...
ganz, ziemlich einen Vorsprung hat.
Ich suche jetzt bloß gerade die Benchmarks dazu.
Hier haben die welche dabei gehabt, ne?
Ja, ach ja, was ich mit dem Rechner machen will...
Also ne, muss ich vorher auch immer mal überlegen,
ähm...
Was will man mit dem Rechner machen?
Bei mir ist das ganz einfach.
Ich will erstmal spielen.
Das ist quasi...
Must have, ja?
Was schneller ist in Spielen,
ist wahrscheinlich auch besser für mich.
So.
Danach will ich natürlich Stream-Rendern.
Das ist das nächste.
Aber ich behaupte mal, dass alle Rechner,
die man sich so zusammenstellen kann,
die richtig gut in aktuellen Spielen sind,
auch locker reichen zum Rendern und Streamen.
Klar, theoretisch ist für Rendern und Streamen
mehr Kerne
potentiell besser als weniger Kerne.
Aber wenn man Rechner hat, der schnell genug ist
für aktuelle Games,
ist es auf jeden Fall schnell genug.
Zumal ich GPU-Encoding für den Stream verwende
und das meine CPU eh nicht weiterjuckt.
Für YouTube verwende ich ganz normales H.264
mit FFM-Pack, das über die CPU.
Da würden vielleicht die zwei Kerne vom Ryzen
ein bisschen was bringen,
aber die Renderzeit,
das wird es nicht dick ausmachen.
Im Prinzip, das ist eigentlich meine Hauptanwendungspack.
Ich will spielen, ich will streamen und rendern.
Was ich nicht will, ist 3D bearbeiten.
Also 3D, ja, sowas wie Blender oder so.
Das will ich nicht machen.
Oder schreiben wir keine 3D Models.
So Blender oder so Dinge,
das will ich nicht machen, ist nicht meins.
Also das heißt, ob die jetzt eine gescheite
OpenGL-Implementierung für die Grafikkarte haben,
das ist mir egal,
zumal ich eh schon eine Grafikkarte habe.
Im Prinzip war es das eigentlich schon,
weil natürlich will ich so Dinge machen
wie surfen, Mails schreiben, bla, bla, bla.
Aber ehrlich, ein Rechner, der das hier oben kann,
hat keine Probleme mit Mails.
Ich will auf jeden Fall, das ist noch eine wichtige,
2-3 Bildschirme will ich haben,
wobei das meine Grafikkarte auch kann, überhaupt kein Ding.
Und was ich unbedingt brauche, ist optischer Sound.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das muss ich unbedingt haben.
So, gucken wir nochmal ein paar PC Games.
Das Hardware, was die so am Start haben.
Ich brauche unbedingt einen optischen Sound-Ausgang.
Für mein Audio-Interface.
Alter, Werbung, piss dich, Alde.
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Den kenne ich, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das könnte sein, da stehen wir auf der...
Wie sieht der Typ aus?
Habe ich den mal auf der Gamescom getroffen?
Der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Hm.
Irgendwie kommt er mir bekannt vor.
Ähm, okay.
Die haben Spiele-Benchmarks.
Interim Limit, yeah.
So, aber gucken wir uns erstmal die Computerbase-Seite fertig an.
Also klar, hier kann natürlich der Ryzen das ein bisschen ausspielen.
Bei Caseking, vielleicht kenne ich ihn noch?
Keine Ahnung.
Mit Caseking hat es ja nicht wirklich viel zu tun.
Okay, ähm...
Ja, was man hier noch als Anforderung drauf schreiben kann,
ist natürlich Video-Bereitung.
Aber das dürfte durch meine SSD schon mal ganz gut abgedeckt sein.
Dass Vegas nicht hängt.
So, was haben die sonst noch für Benchmarks?
Ah, das ist auch ganz interessant.
Also man sieht, das Ding haut schon rein, ja.
So.
Gesamt-Rating Linux.
Ha!
Gucken wir uns das Ganze gerade unter den Jungs an.
Okay, hier gibt es noch mal ein Unigine Valley Benchmark.
Da ist der auch ganz vorne mit dabei.
Aber man sieht hier schon, bei Spielen waren ja die Ryzens jetzt zwar immer nicht zu langsam,
aber auch schon eine letzte Generation nicht vorne mit dabei.
Also aktuell tendiere ich eindeutig zu dem Ding.
Der kostet, glaube ich, um die 400 Euro.
Nein.
Und es ist natürlich auch nicht lieferbar, ist ja klar, ne.
Das Netzteil, also weil ich gerade Diskussionen lese über das Netzteil,
580 Watt Netzteil, das reicht.
Die Zeiten von 1000 Watt Netzteilschwanzvergleich sind vorbei seit 8 Jahren oder so.
Genau, also die CPU kostet mich 400 Euro.
Die CPU kostet mich 400 Euro.
So, da gucken wir uns noch mal die Spielebenchmarks mit...
Pizzee Games Hardware ist auch immer super, was sowas angeht.
So, Crysis 3.
Ich finde es geil, dass Crysis 3 immer noch genommen wird.
Da sieht man, dass ich grafisch, also beziehungsweise von der Entwicklung ja jetzt auch nicht mehr
so rasend schnell vorwärts geht wie früher.
Max, was ist wichtiger, CPU oder Grafikkarte für möglichst hohe FPS?
Das kommt auf das Game an, prinzipiell.
Das kann man doch nicht mal prinzipiell sagen.
Also normal würde ich sagen, wenn die CPU halbwegs aktuell ist und deine Grafikkarte
mega scheiße, dann eine Grafikkarte.
Aber wenn du eh schon eine ganz gute Grafikkarte hast, dann hast du einen mega scheiß CPU.
Also es kommt aufs Game an und es muss halt zueinander passen.
Es muss halt zueinander passen.
Also ich würde sagen, so aus dem Bauch raus, würde ich sagen, je höher die Auflösung
und quasi die Qualitätsstufe im Game, je wichtiger die Grafikkarte, wobei man das auch nicht
so schall sagen kann, weil die Grafikkarte ja auch von der CPU noch anständig was bekommen
muss.
Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel PUBG anguckt, das ist ein Game, das ist nicht sonderlich
hübsch.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es die Grafikkarte gar nicht fordert, aber das braucht ordentlich
CPU und wenn dann deine CPU nicht hinterher kommt, dann bringt dir auch eine schnelle Grafikkarte
nichts.
Du hast andere Games, zum Beispiel das neue Doom, das flutscht auch bei langsamer CPU besser.
PUBG ist da halt so ein Negativbeispiel von.
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Das muss zueinander passen.
Also es hat keinen Sinn, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so eine Einsteiger-CPU holst und 1080 Ti.
Das muss irgendwie zusammenpassen.
Dann kann es nämlich gut sein, dass du die volle Stärke deiner 1080 Ti gar nicht ausspielen
kannst.
Und bei mir ist es ja so, ich stelle ja oftmals eh schon Grafik und so lieber runter, dass
ich mehr FPS habe.
Ich habe einen 144-Hertz-Monitor schon seit 10 Jahren, weil ich es für eine der besten
Erfindungen der letzten Jahre halte in der Richtung.
Und ich hätte am liebsten Minimum 144 FPS eher mehr, sodass quasi wenn es mal tropft,
es quasi nicht unter 144 FPS tropft.
Deswegen stelle ich meistens die Grafik, so ein paar Aufmerworte spiele ich auf fast minimal
Settings.
Außer Renderscale und sowas.
Einfach das muss flutschen, mehr FPS gleich besser, ganz einfach.
Mein alter PC war damals ziemlich gut, preisleistungsmäßig und auch von der Performance.
Ja und mein Xeon ist in die Jahre gekommen, deswegen gucke ich jetzt ja auch gerade nach
einer neuen CPU.
Man muss aber sagen, mein Xeon ist nicht scheiße, auch aus heutiger Sicht nicht.
So in Single-Core-Singleswert-Performance oder Performance mit 1, 2, 3 Kern, was auch immer
ja, was für Games relevant ist oder sag mal 4, ist der Xeon immer noch ziemlich gut dabei.
Es ist nicht so, dass der jetzt total scheiße wäre und die 1080 Ti deswegen rumkrebsen würde.
So schlimm ist der gar nicht.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt nochmal die Spiele Benchmarks an.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt in 1280, gibt es da vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ok, StarCraft ist zum Beispiel ein recht CPU-intensives Spiel.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, ist weniger besser oder mehr besser?
Mehr ist besser, ne?
Was ich jetzt hier nicht wirklich checke ist, warum ist denn der i7 7740X, was auch immer
das für einer jetzt genau gewesen ist, warum ist der schneller in StarCraft als der hier?
Das leuchtet mir nicht so ganz an der Takt bei dem hier ist.
Nein, der Takt ist vielleicht höher im Durchschnitt dann, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest ist der oben mit dabei.
Ryzen kackt hier ein bisschen ab dabei.
Aber StarCraft 2 ist relativ CPU-intensiv.
Cooper, bis letzte Woche habe ich mir noch überlegt, ob ich mir einen Ryzen kaufe.
Aber ich muss sagen, die neue Intel-Plattform überzeugt mich von den Sachen, die ich heute
gelesen habe.
Witcher 3 haut es auch richtig rein und ein Game, das ich garantiert nicht spielen werde,
ist das auch gut dabei.
Also die CPU scheint mir schon eine gute Wahl zu sein.
Was jetzt aber viel interessanter wird, also ich würde sagen, die CPU ist gesetzt.
CPU gibt auf jeden Fall, gibt es so hier einen.
Ich meine, ich habe ja auch genug Budget.
Hätte ich eh, aber zumal ich jetzt noch nicht mal die andere Hälfte von einem Rechner brauche,
weil ich die Teile noch habe.
Also CPU wird ziemlich sicher so einer.
Das kostet um die 400 Euro.
Und die Benchmarks geben dem Ding ja auch recht.
Wenn man sich anguckt, der Schnellste, Moment, hallo, Maus.
Also der ist 30%, 33% schneller als der Schnellste.
In dem Fall jetzt hier in Crysis 3.
Also für Gaming, und das ist ja auch meine erste Anforderung, was ich dir gestellt habe,
Spiele ist das Wichtigste, gefolgt von den anderen Sachen, ist das schon eine gute Wahl.
Was viel komplizierter wird jetzt, sind Mainboards für das Ding.
Da habe ich nämlich noch gar keine Ahnung, was es alles gibt.
Das gucken wir jetzt nämlich mal auf Geizhals, was es da alles für Mainboards gibt.
Ich weiß so, dass es von MSI so Weihnachtsmau.
Wenn ich das schon wieder sehe, ja.
Ach nee, das ist ein Z, das ist gar nicht richtig, ein Mainboard.
Mainboards gibt es schon ein paar.
Doch, Vlogsit, ich habe sogar gelesen, dass manche Mainboards für diese Plattform schon lieferbar sind.
CPUs hingegen nicht.
Könntest du ein gutes Netzteil empfehlen, 500 Watt, was definitiv genug Anschlüsse hat?
Ja, also was ich, ich bin ja ein, auch wenn ich noch einen Be Quiet Netzteil habe,
mit dem man übrigens auch nichts falsch machen kann.
Kann wirklich nichts falsch machen.
Was ich gerne habe, an Netzteilen sind die hier, auch weil die relativ teuer sind.
Sind die, die Seite, ey.
Wozu, ganz ehrlich, wer hat diese Seite designt?
Wenn ich auf die Seite gehe, will ich mir die Details von den Netzteilen angucken
und nicht hier Power Performance Prime, Introduction Features und irgendwie so ein komisches Ding.
Ich will die Netzteile sehen, dazu muss ich natürlich erst runterscrollen, ja.
Ja, such dir hier von eins aus, vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Fanless.
Gibt es das eigentlich mittlerweile schon?
Das wollte ich mir vor einer Weile mal kaufen.
Natürlich nicht.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht.
Ne, die Lieferbarkeit von den Dingern ist manchmal.
Nehm dir eins hier von, das ist mit so die besten Netzteile, die du findest.
Meiner Ansicht nach.
Gibt aber auch noch genug andere gute Hersteller, aber ich mag Seasonic.
Cooper, ist das das Netzteil der Höllenmaschine?
Das wusste ich nicht.
Aber es gibt noch gute andere Netzteile.
Was ist das für ein Lied?
Da.
Offenbach und Karl K.
Wer auch immer das ist.
Okay, machen wir mal wieder auf hier, mal weiter gucken.
So, ich will mir jetzt mal die Mainboards angucken, was es da so gibt.
Nur mal so grob drüber, nicht jedes einzelne Mainboard an sich.
Also was ich gelesen hab, was ich gesehen hab von MSI ist das hier.
Das werde ich mir nicht kaufen, weil, erstens, 465 Euro für ein Mainboard.
Da kostet das Mainboard mehr als mein Prozessor.
Nicht, dass ich da prinzipiell was dagegen hätte.
Die Frage ist nur, was bekommt man dafür?
Und ich sehe da für mich wenig Vorteile drin.
Das Mainboard an sich, muss ich ehrlich sagen, finde ich auch nicht schön.
Übrigens, soll ich euch mal was zeigen?
Ich glaube, ich bin hier gar nicht bei Twitter eingeloggt.
Oh nee.
Ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Ich hab mal ein bisschen gelästert.
Vor einer Weile, schon eine ganze Weile her.
Über MSI und...
Ja, ich hab ein bisschen über MSI, man sieht es jetzt leider nicht.
Ein bisschen über MSI gelästert, auf der anderen Seite bin ich gebannt.
Also die nehmen das sehr ernst, wenn man über ihre Mainboardbeleuchtung lästert.
Da muss man aufpassen.
Das darf man nicht übertreiben, dann gibts den Bannhammer.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht geschafft, dass mich ein Hardwarehersteller gebannt hat.
Was soll ich machen?
Ich glaube, das war wegen diesem Tweet hier.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht warum.
Guck mal, ich hab damals geschrieben, das war 2016, wobei ich bin glaube ich schon länger gebannt.
Ich hab damals geschrieben, man ernsthaft blinkt und leuchtet in der Mainboard.
Warum? Wozu? Ich mein... Hallo?
Da gab es ein bisschen Diskussionen drunter, was auch immer.
Und danach war ich irgendwann gebannt bei MSI.
Na ja.
Ja, Fluxik, ich kann es ja nicht proofen, weil ich mich jetzt hier nicht live auf Twitter einloggen will.
Und wo man eventuell mein Passwort sieht.
Aber...
Picks or didn'ts.
So, also das Mainboard gibt es.
Das ist wohl so das...
Wie nennt man das so?
Premium-Modell von MSI.
Mit dem Namen Godlike Gaming.
Und was ich auch sehr schön finde.
Weil ich mein, ich bin ja schon gebannt, also kann ich jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen lästern.
Was ich auch sehr...
Ich hab übrigens da was ein, mein Mainboard.
Was ich auch geil finde ist, man sieht es hier gar nicht so schön.
Was da alles noch drauf steht.
Das ist auch geil.
Naps, genau. Naps.
Ich will... Hier.
Wo ist MSI Godlike Gaming?
Äh.
Da ist sie. So, so wusste ich gar nicht, dass sie da sind.
Ähm.
Bilder.
Aber das sind hier nicht nur irgendwo in groß.
Auf der MSI Seite gibt es das hier.
Da gibt es das in groß.
Game Her.
Genau.
Ähm.
Da sieht man hier. Godlike Gaming.
Enthusiast.
Unlimited. Und was mir Angst macht.
Ja, als äh...
Sehr audio...
Begeisterter... Moment.
WTF.
Mein Headset ist auf der einen Seite aus. Ich muss das gerade mal entknoten.
Ich bin sofort wieder da.
So, passt.
Ähm.
Was mir als audiobegeisterter Mensch Angst macht.
Ist das hier.
Das macht mir echt Angst auf Mainboard.
So was.
Xtreme Audio Duck.
Da träume ich nachts von.
Von sowas.
Was ich an die Mainboard gut finde.
Optische Ausgang.
Okay.
Ähm.
Das ist mir viel zu teuer.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt. Also.
Man muss sagen. Von den Features her.
Ist das Mainboard schon geil.
Wenn man es braucht.
Man schaut sich hier zum Beispiel mal an.
Dass da irgendwie drei Netzwerkkarten drauf sind.
Mit einem eingebauten Switch.
Dass man quasi sein Nachbar, Rechner und Notebook auch noch mit versorgen kann.
Hey.
Wenn man es braucht. Okay.
Die Sache ist bloß. Ich kann mir auch einen 15 Euro TP Link Switch.
Mit 8 Ports kaufen.
Da brauch ich keine 400 Euro Mainboard.
Aber die haben sich bestimmt schon was beigedacht.
Also das ist mir zu viel.
Das ist mir wirklich zu viel des Guten.
Kann man das einfach.
Kann man das mal nach Preis sortieren?
Wie sortiert man das nach Preis?
Okay. Also das günstigste ist anscheinend das hier.
Srock.
Srock hab ich in meinem Server lustigerweise.
Allerdings dort die Enterprise Serie.
Es gibt von Srock tatsächlich eine Server Serie von Mainboards.
Nennt sich Srock Rack.
Aber ich bin kein allzu großer Srock Fan.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Murtin, wenn du so auf Sound stehst.
Warum dann keine Soundkarte?
Oder hab ich was übersehen?
Weil ich ein Audio Interface hab.
Ziemlich nice ist das Audio Interface.
Was wahrscheinlich Soundtechnisch so ziemlich
alles was du dir an Gaming Soundkarten kaufen kannst
in die Tasche steckt.
Hier hat man ein ganz schönes Bild von.
Genau.
Deswegen brauch ich auch einen optischen Ausgang.
Ganz einfach.
Weil das
über Tossling angeschlossen wird.
Und das ist echt geil das Ding.
Das hat sich gelohnt zu kaufen.
Weil mich manche
einige nach dem
Setup hier gefragt haben.
Mit Konsolen,
PC's und so.
Also immer ganz kurz.
Ich hab das so geregelt.
Ich hab den Spielrechner
hier drinne angeschlossen.
Über optischen Eingang.
Meinen zweiten Rechner hier nebendran.
Den ich halt
nebenbei verwende für
sei es jetzt hier Settings im Stream vornehmen und sowas.
Während ich hier streame.
Über USB
angeschlossen. Das heißt über den kann ich auch das Audiointerface
konfigurieren und sowas.
Vorne ist hier mein Kopfhörer
oder meine beiden Kopfhörer.
Das MMX300 Headset
und ein billiger
Creative Kopfhörer.
Und hier an die anderen
Anschlüsse
die es hier noch gibt
an diesem Audiointerface.
Da hab ich alles andere dran.
Da hab ich die Konsolen dran angeschlossen.
Und
die Mikrofone
dran angeschlossen.
Noch einen kleinen Mixer
für
jetzt hier das Headset
Mikro und für weitere Inputs.
Da könnte ich beispielsweise mein iPhone
dran anschließen und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das kann ich dann hier mit alles schön zusammenmischen und
aufs Ohr.
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch.
Nebendem das die Quali natürlich auch super ist.
Ähm
Verbessert eine Soundkarte den Sound
von einem Headset oder von Kopfhörern?
Ähm
Nee, aber sie kann sie verschlechtern.
Weißt du wie ich das mein?
Also
Ähm
Also wenn du einen guten Kopfhörer hast
der wird nicht besser
quasi durch
den
der kann nicht auf einmal mehr als das was er eh kann.
Aber ähm
wenn du jetzt eine Soundkarte
anschließt oder irgendwie einen
Ja eigentlich kommt es ja auf den
auf den Digital Analog
Konverter an.
Und dann kann es schon sein
dass das halt kacke klingt je nachdem.
Weil es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass du gutes Material
hast. Also wenn du jetzt da mit irgendwelchen
128 MP3s
oder so ankommst
Ähm
Aimfreaks
wieso was hast du nicht verstanden an dem Video
über Headsets? Die meisten
Gaming Headsets, es gibt mittlerweile ein paar ganz
brauchbare Gaming Headsets, aber die meisten
Gaming Headsets die sind ziemlich
sinnlos und überteuert.
Also Preis-Leistungen sind die meisten
Gaming Headsets
nicht der Wahnsinn.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Mainboards weiter an.
So, das sieht
natürlich scheiße aus im Vergleich zu
dem super blinkenden
Godlike Ultimate MSI
Mainboard.
Was, was hat denn das?
Oh, das hat eine super Bewertung.
Das sieht mir zu kacke aus
irgendwie. Das sieht protestlich aus.
Also nicht dass ich wirklich Wert darauf
liegen würde wie mein Mainboard aussieht
ja, aber das sieht aus wie
1992 das
Mainboard.
Das sieht aus wie draufgekackt.
Ne, das ist scheiße.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
So, MSI Gaming
Plus. Das hört sich, das
sieht schon mal ein bisschen stylischer aus.
Ein bisschen stylisch darf das Mainboard ja aussehen.
Das ist ja okay.
Wir können auch mal gucken was Asus hat.
Was hat denn Asus?
Asus Prime. Yeah.
Gucken wir uns mal stellvertretend ein paar Mainboards an.
Was es da so gibt.
Warum hat eigentlich, wir machen
das jetzt mal nach Herstellern kurz.
Warum hat eigentlich MSI
Mainboards für die neue Plattform?
Was ist denn da der große Unterschied?
Außer dass die
dass das Godlike Gaming
Ultimate, Enthusiast, Extreme Audio
Duck ganz toll ist.
Gibt es hier auch eine
schönere Übersicht von den Fähigkeiten?
Man kann doch bei MSI bestimmt
Mainboards vergleichen.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Äh, nicht Notebook.
Products, Mainboards.
Kann man das nicht
Kategorie übergreifen, vielleicht vergleichen.
Äh,
Z
Ah, da.
Okay, man kann das
man kann das kompären.
Wir kompären jetzt mal die MSI Mainboards.
Was da so der Unterschied ist.
Also das will ich auf keinen Fall.
Das ist mir auf jeden Fall zu teuer.
Das können wir schon mal weglassen.
So, wir kompären das
mal, mal gucken was da
dann am Ende rauskommt.
Mehr kann ich nicht kompären.
Oh man, warum?
Da blickt doch wieder
keiner durch, ey.
Auf Amazon haben die eine Vergleichlist.
Das war ein Ding.
So, also was können die jetzt?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen den Mainboards?
Und das hier ist alles das gleiche.
PC Express
Slots.
Also drei
PC Express Slots brauche ich.
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall drei
PC Express Slots. Für einmal
natürlich Grafikkarte.
Und
Erzbergkarte.
Eventuell nochmal
eine Capture Card wieder rein.
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall drei PC Express
Anschlüsse. Ohne geht nicht.
Warte mal eine Sekunde, ich muss doch kurz was zu trinken holen.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Okay, also
Drei PC Express Anschlüsse
Must have. Das muss ich mir hier auch
gleich mal aufschreiben.
Brauche ich. Geht nicht anders.
Das heißt
Das Ding fällt schon mal raus.
So.
Ja.
Ja, Herzwerkanschluss brauche ich eigentlich eh nicht.
Ich brauche, also es
sollte auf jeden Fall ein
Gigabit
Dingskarte haben.
Aber
Ihr wisst vielleicht
Zumindest die, die mein Serverraum-Video geguckt haben, für die die es nicht geguckt haben,
zeige ich das nochmal kurz, also den wichtigen Part, ich habe nämlich hier einen, äh, zeige
ich es dann. Hier, ich habe nämlich einen 10 Gigabit Switch und deswegen kommt in den
einen PCI Express Anschluss eine 10 Gigabit SFP plus Netzwerkkarte rein. Ich muss mal
kurz den Bein noch was futtern. Ich bin jetzt quasi von der Arbeit gekommen, ausgestiegen
aus dem Zug und habe direkt Streben angemacht. Der ist unten drunter MediCat, der T-Pill-China-Router.
Da habe ich weggeklickt, aber er hat genug Anschlüsse, ne, das hat er bloß zweimal
gepizzt, ich stand doch da. Ah, Moment! Ah, Moment! Die machen es einem aber auch immer
schwer, muss ich sagen. So, was hatten wir ausgewählt, die Dinger, ne? Warum kann es
nicht eigentlich noch mehr kompären, was soll das denn? Dann kompären wir danach die
anderen. Oh, ok. Preis, steht hier Preis? Preis gibt es nicht. Ähm, ok, das, hä? Moment,
wo ist es denn jetzt? What the fuck, wo ist es denn eben hin von dem was ich eben ausgewählt
habe? Kann es sein, dass die Seite nicht immer gleich sortiert? Egal, machen wir noch mal.
Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack. Go. Jaja. Ach, ich habe in der zweiten Reihe von rechts angefahren
beim ersten Mal. Na gut, fangen wir jetzt von links an, das ist auch irgendwie intuitiver.
Also, auf jeden Fall genug, auf jeden Fall auch genug SATA Anschlüsse, M2 Slots ist
nice to have, nicht dass ich sie brauchen würde. USB Ports reicht mir auch. USB 3.1 reicht
mir auch. Ähm, die Mainboards mit Grafikausgängen, ich vermute mal, das ist einfach nur Verlängerung
für die CPU Grafikkarte, oder? Weiß das jemand? So war das zumindest früher. Also,
das wird voll und ganz ausreichen. Optical SPDIF, gut. Also, eigentlich reicht da fast
jedes Mainboard. Warum soll ich mir denn jetzt so ein super, ein super high-end, things extreme,
gaming oder was auch immer, da nehmen wir jetzt, da gucken wir jetzt einfach mal bei
Geizhals, das billigste von MSI, was es gibt, was nicht total beschissen aussieht. Das sieht
beschissen aus, das will ich nicht. Also, das sieht, das sieht, das sieht richtig beschissen
aus. Ähm, das hier, das ist, das ist zum Beispiel das billigste. So, das hat 2x PCI-Expression,
oder? Also, müssen wir mal irgendwie, sagen wir mal so 150 Euro fürs Mainboard. Wieso
nur MSI, weil ich das erstmal nur noch MSI sortiert habe. Danach gucken wir uns die anderen
Sachen an. Es sind doch 3. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Das reicht mir, ich brauche ja keine 3, 3
große. Ich brauche einfach 3. Hat kein Torschling? Doch. Warum ist das so scheiße, warum stimmt
das nicht? Ich sehe hier keinen Torschling, keinen optischen zumindest. Ne, ich, ne Nilsson,
ich sehe ihn nicht. Das hat, das hat kein, das hat kein. Dann fällt es schonmal flach.
So, nächste. Tomahawk. Der hat einen. Torschling-Buchse, ne, das finde ich. Das von Anschluss näher
schonmal ganz gut. 3x PCI-Express, ne, wie ist das richtige dafür? PCI-Express ist alle,
wie heißen die langen? PCI 16? E? Ach, immer. Zumindest hat das auf jeden Fall genug Steckplätze
und sieht nicht ganz so beschissen aus. Also, das könnte man sich schonmal kaufen. Das hat
einen, einen ordentlichen, das hat einen optischen Ausgang, das ist das wichtigste. Hat, wie
viel USB hat das? Das PC hat es. Da. Das ist USB 10, ne? Ja. Das hat USB, da kannst
du, kannst du, kannst du den Salat draus machen, so viel USB hast du hier. Das, also, ganz
ehrlich, das, das wird mir reichen, ja. Irgendwelche super Overclocking-Geschichten brauche ich
eh nicht. Also, das könnte, das könnte, das könnte man schonmal ins nähere Auge fassen,
so. Wichtig, ganz wichtig, ja. Beleuchtung RGB, ganz wichtig. So, was haben sie sonst?
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum braucht MSI, warum brauchen die 10 Mainboards? Guck
mal, und die meisten Mainboards liegen gerade mal 45, na, na sagen wir mal so, die meisten
Mainboards liegen 50 Euro auseinander im Preis. Warum, warum machen die nicht einfach drei?
Quasi ein Einsteiger-Modell, ein mittleres und ein Highend-Modell. Sebaro, das ist eine
gute Idee. Nummer von dem Ding notieren, das Teil da. So, was, was, was haben wir als
nächstes? SLI plus, SLI habe ich keine, SLI brauche ich nicht. Ach, die Dinger sind
für Grafikkarten oder was? Und das hier nicht. Warum, das muss, das, das muss mir mal einer
erklären. Warum sind die hier für Grafikkarten und das nicht? Das passt doch auch. Also,
ich habe aber keine, ich brauche kein SLI. Keine Ambitionen. MSI Crate Gaming, oder,
Kreit, MSI Kreit Gaming. Verstärkt für hohes Gericht, aha. Weil die Lanes an der CPU hängen.
Ja, wo sollen die Lanes denn sonst hängen, wenn nicht an der CPU? Haben alle 16 Pins,
jetzt sollte der hier doch auch haben. Ach so, der untere sieht nur aus, dass es quasi
ordentlich hält und es hat nur, ist nur vielfach. Ne, guck doch mal, dreimal PCI 16. Ah, Moment.
Einmal 16, einmal 8. Man kann die Leute aber auch echt verwirren. Man kann die Leute aber
auch echt verwirren. Ich meine, das ist ja schön und gut. Also wahrscheinlich wollen
sie uns hiermit sagen, es gibt dreimal PCI 16fach Stecker, also Buchsen, wo 16 Geräte
reinpassen, aber angebunden sind die nur mit 16, 8 und 4. Oder wie? Also sprich 16, 8,
4. Ne, 16, doch 16, 8, 4. Warum nennen sie das dann 16, warum nennen sie das nicht einfach
einmal 16, einmal 8, einmal 4. Wird mir aber auch reichen, ehrlich gesagt. Da kommt eine
Grafikkarte rein, hier unten kommt die Capturekarte rein, da kommt die Netzwerke rein. Scheiß
egal, wie rum. Handbreite reicht eh dicke. So, das vergleichen wir jetzt nochmal auf
der MSI Seite. Oder gucken wir erstmal das andere an. Also das wird mir aber auch reichen,
ich meine, es sind zwar nur 10 Euro, aber warum sollte ich mehr ausgeben. Ja, und das
hier hat, ah ok, das hier hat 16, 4 und 1. Ok, ok, verstehe. Ok, wir kommen der Sache
näher. Also das wäre auch noch eine Option, auch wenn MSI mich gebannt hat. GamingPro
Carbon. Was kann der denn jetzt besser? Der sieht fancy aus. Das macht wahrscheinlich
schonmal die 15 Euro Aufpreis aus, das leuchtet. KappaPride. Das leuchtet wirklich so, ne? Ok,
das hat auch 16, 8. 16, 8, 4. Optischer Dosslink, so muss das sein. Diesen tollen Error Indicator,
auf den sie jetzt herrscht. Ist echt ganz praktisch. Also ich flame mir immer ganz gern
mal alles so, was es so gibt, aber diese Anzeigen mit Fehlern sind wirklich ganz praktisch.
Was ich auch gut finde, sind Anschalter auf dem Mainboard. Nicht unbedingt must have,
aber ich finde Resetschalter und Anschalter auf dem Mainboard auch ganz praktisch. Was
ist da jetzt der große Unterschied zwischen dem und dem anderen? Der hat wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen mehr USB. Die vergleichen wir. Die vergleichen wir gleich mal. Wir suchen
das jetzt fünf raus, die fünf billigsten, die passen und vergleichen wir die mal auf
der MSI Seite. Ok, also gibt es ja im Prinzip nur noch die zwei. Dann haben wir noch das
Gaming M5. Das hat das gleiche Pins. Oh, das sieht schon viel stylischer aus. Und hat
auch hier schon die ersten bunten Sachen dran. Ich habe das Gefühl, was sich an den Mainboards
hauptsächlich ändert, ist, dass das fast noch obendrauf gesteckt ist. Na ja, das sollte
eigentlich nicht passieren. Oh, der Neilsson ist der beste. Ok, da können wir vergleichen.
Das fällt eh schon mal raus, weil zu teuer. Was mich aber interessieren würde, was an
dem jetzt so geil ist. Außer, dass es halt Netzwerkkarten und so hat, drei Stück. Ok,
das hat vier PC Express. Einmal 16, einmal 8, zweimal 4. Ok, das hat noch mehr M2 Slots,
da brauche ich eh nicht. Jetzt mal ernsthaft, jemand, der nicht so technikaffin ist, das
müssen doch absolut böhmische Dörfer sein, oder? Das könnte schon fast als Verschlüsselung
durchgehen hier. Wenn mir einer das hier schicken würde, nur diesen Abschnitt, dann würde
ich ihn fragen, ja, mit was hast du das verschlüsselt? Gib mal Passwort. Das ist ok, das ist aber
nichts, wo ich sagen würde, jawoll, lass einfach mal 465 Euro für den Mainboard ausgeben.
Das geht, du kannst beim Windows Installer sagen, du willst reparieren. Aber besser
ist du sicherst den Kram vorher. Dann haben wir noch ein E-Key. Was ist denn ein E-Key?
Werbung, geh weg. Ich dachte, das ist irgendwie eine Pinbelege oder so bei M2.
Achso, ach, das ist für Wireless Karten, ok. Gut, brauche ich alles nicht. Bluetooth brauche
ich auch nicht. Für was brauche ich Bluetooth? Wenn ich Bluetooth unbedingt brauche, kann
ich mir auch einen Bluetooth-Stecker an USB machen. Das ist nix, das brauche ich alles
nicht. USB, C, ganz viele Dreier, Killer-Netzwerkkarte brauche ich auch nicht. Will ich gar nicht,
ich will mal eine 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte verwenden. Einmal Toslink, einmal PS2, ganz
wichtig. RGB, also ich kann verstehen, dass das das Flaggschiff ist, aber wirklich brauchen
tut man das nicht. So, also konzentrieren wir uns mal eher auf die hier. Die zwei fliegen
schon mal komplett raus. Das, weil es einfach pothässlich aussieht. Und ich glaube, dass
man sich genug Slots hat oder irgendwie sowas. Weil das kleinste Mainboard, was wir uns rausgesucht
haben, war das Tomahawk. Bei dem hier, bei dem hier gab es keinen optischen Ausgang.
Steht hier eins dabei, das es optisch hat? Nee, steht er dabei. Das hier hatte, genau,
das sieht hässlich aus und die hatten glaube ich keinen optischen Ausgang. Das heißt,
das kleinste mögliche ist das hier. Gaming plus ist identisch mit dem ersten Ball nur
in rot gefärbt. Perfekt. Tatsächlich, guck mal, das ist genau das gleiche, bloß rot.
Also das kleinste mögliche ist das hier. SLI plus ist, weil der hier noch mit mehr
Lanes angebunden ist, weil du hier 16, 8fach hast, hier hast du plus 16, 16 und 4. Okay,
also die Ausstattung hier würde ich sagen ist exakt gleich, aber wirklich auf den Buchstaben
gleich. Nicht nur hier, die alle, oder? Die haben alle exakt die gleiche Ausstattung.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe. Die haben alle exakt genau das gleiche. Das heißt, da
kann es keine Unterschiede geben. Oder was ist, was ist der Unterschied zwischen denen
hier oben? Ja, die Anschlüsse, das sehe ich, aber hier bei den Erweiterungsslots ist keine
Unterschiede. Okay, das heißt. Okay, also die sind die gleichen. Hier, der ist halt
nur vierfach. Also das hier sind die gleichen im Endeffekt. Grob drüber scannen hier. Ja,
ne? Okay, also die gehen alle, die gehen alle hier, die. Und das fällt raus, weil es einfach
zu teuer ist. Zur Anschlüsse haben wir hier, ne gut, DVI-HMI, ne, das ist mir, ich brauche
kein Displayport. Ich habe meine Grafiker da drinnen, also ich schließe eh nichts an.
Das wird grün hinterlegt, wenn die, ich sehe hier nichts, grün hinterlegt das. Ach so,
wenn du drüber gehst. Cool, cool, ha, also die Seite ist echt gut. Das ist echt gut,
die Seite, das gefällt mir. Das gefällt mir. Okay, das heißt, aha, die Seite ist echt
gut zum vergleichen. Gut, hier ist der Unterschied, die haben Displayport. Und die hier hat, der
hier hat schon Killer-Netzwerkkarte. Und das AC ist quasi das Carbon mit Wi-Fi. Oder?
Hätte ich jetzt mal so vom Namen gedacht. So der Unterschied, Displayport ist mir vollkommen
gut. Und die Anschlüsse reichen mir auch. Ganz ehrlich, das ist okay, das reicht. Einmal
USB-C, einmal USB-3.1, viermal USB-3 und zweimal USB-, das reicht. Locker. Das sind
Kartenanschlüsse, also, oder wahrscheinlich auf dem Board nur. Das Sound ist auch fast
über alles gleich. Zwei Netzwerkkarten? Zwei? Zwei Soundkarten? Zwei Soundkarten? Okay,
also warum nicht? Dann halt zwei Soundkarten. Sind die Grafikkartenpreise von Bitcoin-Mining
immer noch so hoch? Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt hab, war das, war der Fall, aber nicht
bei allen Grafikkarten. Ja, 140 Leute schauen sich Mainboards an. Ganz ehrlich, das kleinste
Reicht. So, das reicht. Das hier. Ich will kein SLI machen. Ich bin absolut kein SLI-Fan.
Das reicht. Das ist okay. Auf der anderen Seite, der andere Seite, die fünf Euro, die
das jetzt ausmacht, das ist auch nicht so wild, oder? Ja, also, im Prinzip eins hiervon. Im
Prinzip eins hiervon. So, gucken wir jetzt noch mal schnell, was die anderen Hersteller
haben. Guck mal, Asus. Asrock hab ich keinen Bock. Nilsson, kann ich jetzt quasi, du hast
es hier eben eingerichtet, kann ich jetzt hier quasi, ja stimmt doch, steht sogar schon
Vergleich da. Ich wähl die einfach alle aus und dann machen wir Vergleich. Easy. GG. Dann
gucken wir uns erstmal die billigen an, die ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht will, weil da
irgendwas fehlt. Wisst ihr, schau mal, kein optischen Ausgang. Schau mal, kein optischen
Ausgang. Optischer Ausgang. Passt doch, passt doch. Können wir die zwei nämlich wegmachen?
Die zwei dabei. Gut. Also, schauen wir mal an, was Asus jetzt hier zu bieten hat. Ich
nehm' nur ich das so kryptisch. Also, so generell die Auswahl bei Mainboards, das ist so ganz
viele verschiedene Produkte mit minimalen Unterschieden, immer so fünf Euro im Preis
auseinander. Können die Hersteller nicht einfach machen, irgendwie billig Produkt, dann so,
sagen wir mal so Einsteiger, Mittel und Highend. Das wird doch reichen. Du brauchst doch hier
keine 14 Mainboards oder sowas. Mini-ITX. Äh. Ähm. Also hier ist, hier ist Wifi und
Getöntes dabei, das ist Overkill, das brauch ich nicht. Netzwerkabeln, beste. So, was
ist denn das? Einmal 16, einmal 8, einmal 2, ok. Und das sieht wenigstens auch schon,
aber Asus sieht wenigstens auch das Einsteiger-Mainboard nicht so hässlich aus. Also das, das wird's
auch tun. Einmal, wie viel USB haben wir? 2x3.1, 4x3.0, 2x2, Tosslink optisch, hoffe
ich mal. Ich hoffe die haben alle Tosslink optisch. Steht ja nicht dabei. Ah die sollten
alle Tosslink optisch haben. Ja. Naja. Sie brechen mir ja auch das billigste. Kann die
Mainboards oben wegklicken? Wo? Da? Wo kann man die wegklicken? Nee, ich wollte es ja
hier aus der Auswahl entfernen. Aber, so wie ich das sehe, kann ich auch bei Asus fast
das günstigste nehmen. So, überhaupt kein Ding. Also bei Asus kommen auch, also das
hier ist, das ist wieder Overkill, das brauch ich nicht. Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, Mainboards,
es geht eigentlich fast alles bis auf die billigsten. So, dann gucken wir als letztes
jetzt nochmal uns die Mainboards an von, gucken wir uns als letztes nochmal die Mainboards
an von, komm wir schauen auch nochmal ASRock, was die so haben. Das geht, ich finde das
geht optisch, das sieht nicht ganz so draufgekackt aus wie das von MSI. Aber kein optischer
Toslink, das ist Ausschlusskriterium, schau mal. Direkt in die Tonne, kein optischer Toslink,
Wifi, würde ich sagen. Ja, für Antennen. Optischer Toslinks, erste hier, auch mit Wifi.
Why not? Also anscheinend sollte man sich ASRock auch mal angucken. ASRock Fatality,
gibt es den überhaupt noch? Ich glaube der spielt jetzt, der spielt jetzt Pupke, hab
ich gesehen hier, der Fatality. Pupke-Owner ist es geworden. War eine Frage an den Nielson,
was würdest du nehmen? Kein Optischer Toslink, kein Optischer Toslink, kein Optischer Toslink,
kein Optischer Toslink, na bei Gigabyte ist das ja gerade einfach. Kein Optischer Toslink,
noch nicht mal Bilder. Optischer Toslink, ok. Prinzip gibt es noch nie zu vergleichen.
Gigabyte scheint so ziemlich Antitoslink zu sein. Nielson, von den ganzen Mainbots insgesamt,
hättest du da ein Favorit, unabhängig von welcher Marke, falls du diese schon mal angeguckt
hast. Ok, noch ganz kurz mal angucken was MSI so am Start hat, äh Gigabyte so am Start
hat. Was ist hier der Unterschied? Einmal 8, einmal 4. Das ist hier der Unterschied.
Einmal MQ, zweimal Gigabyte, na das brauch ich nicht. Auch wieder Killer Networks, das
scheint bei den High End Boards so, was ist da, Verkaufsschlager. Einmal Thunderbolt. Das
war das hier, ne? War das das Crate Gaming oder das Tomahawk, was du meinst? Also im
Prinzip die gehen auch fast alle. Also ganz ehrlich, Mainboard ist diesmal, Mainboard
muss man in der ruhigen Minute nochmal angucken, aber das kann man bis auf die Einsteiger Mainbots
eigentlich, was heißt Einsteiger, das Zeug ist immer noch doppelt bis dreifach so teuer
wie normalerweise. Also bis auf die günstigsten der Serien kann man das eigentlich fast alles
kaufen. Mainboards ist wirklich Detailfrage mittlerweile. Ok, gut, ich mein, was brauchen
wir da als letztes noch? Also wir müssen das auf jeden Fall, ich guck jetzt mal welches
E-Mainboard der Nileson meint. Das Tomahawk, ne? Das fand ich sah auch gut aus. Das fand
ich, das war eine gute Konkurrenz, das ist schön billig, also immer noch dreimal dreimal
zum allen Mainboards, aber es ist relativ günstig, hat alles dabei was man braucht.
Also wahrscheinlich wird es das hier. Machen wir nochmal ein Fragezeichen dahinter, sind
wir bei 150, schreiben wir einfach mal hin. Für was ich mein PC hauptsächlich nutzen
will ist, ganz klar, spielen, das wichtigste und natürlich streamrendern. Wobei halt ein
PC der das kann, das auch gut kann. Man kann zwar einen Rechner basteln, der das hier besser
kann als das, aber jeder Rechner der spielen kann, der man gut spielen kann, kann man das
auch machen und der Rest ist eh nix besonderes. So, RAM, gut DDR4 RAM halt, ne? Ist zur Zeit
relativ teuer, wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab. Wie viel RAM Stecker hat denn das Ding?
Vier Stück. Ah, kein Ding. Ja, Narunokaze, ich verwende den Onboard Sound nicht. Also
ich verwende den Onboard, das was auf Sound auf dem Mainboard drauf ist, verwende ich rein
per optischem Kabel an mein Audiointerface. Ich verwende nichts von dem, was das kann.
Ich habe an dem Mainboard von meinem aktuellen Gaming-Rechner außer dem optischen Anschluss
ist noch nicht eine Audiobuchse verwendet worden. So, was kann es denn für RAM? Gibt
es, hey, gibt es einen Mainboard, was, jetzt waren wir so richtig, so richtig budget, gibt
es einen Mainboard, was DDR3 kann? Nee, oder? Nee, wird es nicht geben. Könnte ich nämlich
mein alter RAM weiterverwenden. Der Geschmack und Geschwindigkeitsunterschied macht es wahrscheinlich
eh nicht fett. Und das hier ist es. So, was will der RAM? Viermal DDR4. Gucken wir mal
mal. Gut, ich mein, langsamerer wird er natürlich auch gehen.
was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen, mal angenommen, zwischen 4GHz, also preislich
muss ich jetzt mal gucken. Der Unterschied zwischen 4GHz, sagen wir mal, und 2006. Warum
muss ich denn jetzt diesen, äh? Ah, Moment. Preis pro Gigabyte 38. Ähm, das macht keinen
Unterschied. Oh nee, Moment, ich bin am falschen. Oh, das macht einen Unterschied. Wollte ich
gerade sagen, weil ich brauch gar keinen RAM, damit der so viel Wumms hat. Die mit dem
Einbord wollten wir bloß sagen, man kann maximal. Ja, da sind wir doch schon in günstigeren
Gefällen. Äh, Lord, Andy, Mion, lohnt sich so viel Gigabyte überhaupt? Nee. Generell,
also die, also mehr RAM, also RAM-Übertakten oder beziehungsweise da irgendwie besonders
auch gezüchteten RAM kaufen, das lohnt sich selten. Das lohnt sich wirklich ganz selten.
Früher hattest du das Problem, dass wenn du quasi übertaktet hast, du ein gesamtes System
übertaktet hast, also sprich nicht nur den CPU-Takt, dann musstest du manchmal schnelleren
RAM kaufen, dass das funktioniert oder du musstest zumindest den Teiler runterstellen fürs RAM,
dass der der PC nicht abkackt. Aber soweit, ich weiß, ich hab schon lange nichts mehr übertaktet,
ich bin immer klargekommen, die letzten paar Generationen, ach, das haben sie recht,
die waren halt auch immer ziemlich gut mit der Standard-Config. Mittlerweile kannst
du, glaub ich, den CPU-Takt so alles so einstellen. G-Skill, RipJaws, boah, das klingt ja schon
wieder, oh, das ist wieder so ein RAM, der gegen meinen CPU-Lüfter stößt. CPU-Lüfter
müssen wir auch gleich nochmal was gucken, wobei, wir haben ja schon geklärt, mein alter
CPU-Lüfter passt eigentlich. Vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch einen neuen CPU-Lüfter. Guck
mal, wir haben jetzt, wir haben noch so, wir haben so wenig in Anführungsstrichen ausgegeben
jetzt. Wir sind jetzt gerade noch mal bei 550 Euro, da kommt jetzt nochmal RAM dabei
für, weiß ich. So, warum dann Z370, wenn du nicht OC machst? Ja, was denn sonst, das
gibt ja sonst nix. Gibt ja sonst für die neue Intel-CPUs nix. So, da kommt jetzt,
da kommt jetzt 2x8 rein, um gut ist. So, Crucial Ballistics Elite. Das sind zwei Stück,
2x8. Ah ja, easy. Also, sagen wir mal, 150 Euro kostet das RAM nochmal obendrauf. 150,
also RAM kostet nochmal 150 Euro. Da ist eigentlich fast egal, was ich hier nehme,
hier, die Dinger sind glaube ich relativ flach. Beim letzten Rechner hatte ich mir auch so
Cousin-Dinger gekauft, da habe ich dann den Kühler abgemacht, dass der CPU-Lüfter gepasst
hat. Also RAM, der einfach noch aussieht wie RAM-Riegel gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr,
oder? Es ist ja nicht so, dass der Scheiß was bringen würde, weil ich meine, was bringt
dem RAM-Riegel das? Als hätte der davon jetzt irgendwas. Alles krasse Namen, krass gestylt.
Ach so, ein einfacher RAM-Riegel, das gibt es nicht mehr. Naja, also 150 Euro für RAM,
dann nehme ich einfach den, der lieferbar ist und am billigsten in dem Shop. Kauf doch
RGB-RAM, gibt es RAM mit RGB-Beleuchtung? Das muss ich jetzt mal RAM gucken. Ach du Scheiße,
das gibt es ja wirklich. Wobei, ich muss sagen, ich muss sagen, also ich finde das harmonischer
irgendwie und hübscher als der Weihnachtsbaum auf dem Mainboard. Das würde ich sogar benutzen.
Kostet dann einfach mal 80 Euro mehr als der andere RAM, aber ich meine RGB-Beleuchtung,
ja? Mech, du hast RGB-RAM. Hast du den selbst gekauft oder ist der Rechner gesponsort? Disclaimer,
please. Äh, nicht Disclaimer, Disclosure. Ähm, also, nee, nee, nee, kein RGB-RAM. War
das ein Sponsort-PC? Das dachte ich mir. Na dann, wenn es ein Sponsort-PC ist, dann packen
die ja immer alles umso abgespace, umso besser. Ja, wir machen hier irgendwie Crucial Ballistix,
Elite Dim. Nee, äh, äh, eh, denkst hier, da, warte, äh, acht. Wo ist es hier acht?
Ah hier, den machen wir rein. Das ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht. Zwei Stück oder die hier
Zwei stück ist es
Ram kostet 150
Es ist ich werde ich werde den ram rein packen der in dem jeweiligen shop verfügbar ist und am billigsten
Zu dem tag wo ich bestelle
So im prinzip reicht das so jetzt gucken wir doch abschließend einmal wegen cpu lüfter
Weil ich habe mir gerade überlegt ich könnte mein jetziges mainboard
Einfach eins zu eins so rausbauen inklusive
Ram und allem
Und cpu lüfter und baus einfach in anderes gehäuse ein und löst meinen jetzigen zweiten rechner
damit ab
Wenn lüfter dann noch tour ja noch tour hat geile lüfter das stimmt wirklich geile lüfter habe ich in meinem sauberen noch turlüfter
Was haben die denn so
Ich
D 14 schreibt
Sind teuer das an cpu lüfter spare ich nicht
Es gibt so sachen wo ich mir mittlerweile ab gewöhnt habe daran zu sparen ich spare nicht mehr
Ich spare nicht mehr an gehäuse ich spare nicht mehr an netzteil und ich spare nicht mehr an cpu lüfter
Das sind die sachen wo man wo es am einfachsten ist quasi zu sagen mal ein bisschen billiger aber da spare ich nicht mehr dran
Ich bin auch mittlerweile ziemlich empfindlich wenn man rechner wenn ich mein rechner höre also beim spiel mit setz hat kein problem
Aber im desktop betrieb muss das nahezu seinen sein und auch tour ist gut
Vor allem ich habe noch nie in meinem leben so einen hochwertigen lüfter gesehen wie noch tour
Also auch auch die ganze die ganze packung aufmachung und was da an
Zubehörteilen dabei ist ja also von von verlängerungskabel zum kabel irgendwie zum zum zum
zum trosseln
Dann diese gummifüßchen und sowas weil man hat mich wirklich begeistert
Was ist verklebt
Ach so
Ja gut das braune bein auktor sieht nicht wirklich hübsch aus das stimmt schon
Warum keine wasserkühlung weil ich nicht über takte und luft reicht und
Ich immer noch kein fan von wasser im rechner bin und ich nicht weiß wo ich den wärmetausch dahinstellen soll und
weil ich nicht übertakten will
Weil ich nicht übertakten will und luft leise genug ist
So nu 14 ist top
Der da nee nhu 14 s
Was nach der unterschied
Das ding heißt sogar gleich sieht aber anders aus
Ene game ich mein das ding wo halt die lüfter dran sind
Ach so
Ja aber wozu wozu wärme kühlt das ist sogar teurer als noch
Okay die lüfter sind sind ordentlich kostbill was
Das ist c14 das u14 also
Da beiß ich vielleicht nur mal in den armen sauren abflug holen wir noch den den als lüfter dabei
Naja im desktop betrieb sind die doch bestimmt alle leise
Naja im desktop betrieb sind die sind doch bestimmt alle leise
Gehst du zur plus konne
Die bent kann ich
Für wie die lüfter lese ich mir ein paar tests durch guck mir doch mal was es irgendwie
PC games hardware
Keine cp
Mal da jetzt auf tribal
spicy
Hardware
der beste der beste single tower kühler na wenn ich das schon lese dann
Mache ich das ja schon gleich schaff hier auf den auf den lüfter
Werbung
In deinem f4 hast du keine auktur lufter ich höre auch in meinem server keine auktur lufter
Guck dir auch mal den be quiet pure rock an ok guck ich guck ich auch mal
Welchen
slim nicht slim was ist das für eine distribution man jarro mit i3 wm wenn dich interessiert wie das
Eingerichtet ist kannst du dir das letzte video angucken tabaluga 110 weil da haben wir das zusammen eingerichtet von
Anfang an mit minimal installationen bis zu desktop mit allem was du hier so siehst
Das line up ist also internet ist heute quasi heute ist wahrscheinlich die ndl gefallen gehe ich mal von aus
aus und ich habe gelesen bei einigen shops dass die
cpus lieferbar sind quasi so ab ab 19 20 rum
Vielleicht aber schneller
Ja gut der kostet aber auch nur die hälfte also das ist auch schon also ok
Der um also wirklich die die qualität von den auktur lufter die ist wirklich geil die ist wirklich geil
Die sind zwar nicht sonderlich hübsch aus ja aber das ist wirklich 1a
Kühlleistung
um die laut und laut stärke und blablabla blablabla blablabla blablablabla blablabla
Dort wird erstörbar
Einfache Montage finde ich immer gut.
Okay was ist NFA 15? Sind das Gehäuse Lüfter von denen oder wie?
Ja anscheinend. Das ist das Gehäuse Lüfter von denen. Brauche ich nicht.
Einen finde ich gut. Lautstärke? Haben die Lautstärke gemessen?
Drehzahl? Ah hier Lautstärke.
Na gut 35 höre ich schon. Wobei ob ich die aus dem Gehäuse, na doch.
Also wenn es hier im Arbeitszimmer ruhig ist, ich bin da recht, ich höre sowas immer ganz gut raus.
Das werde ich auch aus dem geschlossenen Gehäuse hören. Na bei mir im Zimmer ist
definitiv keine 34 bis 39, garantiert nicht. Wenn ich, wenn ich, ich habe, ich habe einen
Laut, ich lege jetzt mal einen Laut in den Messgerät ins Zimmer, wartet mal kurz.
Ich lege das jetzt mal auf meinem Stuhl hier mitten ins Zimmer.
Ich habe gerade zwei Rechner an und das komplette Equipment hier sonst noch und die Rechner höre
ich auch. Also 35 höre ich. Aber das ist nicht so, dass es stören würde großartig.
Aber ein bisschen leiser könnte das ganze schon sein.
Naja, also. Aber ich, ich, ich finde den Noctua Lüfter, also ich, ich habe ja hier ein paar
im Einsatz und die Qualität hat mich schon überzeugt. Also vielleicht werde ich mit
den auch noch noch einen holen in der Richtung oder ich nehme den bisschen günstigeren.
Was hat eben noch jemand empfohlen, diesen Be Quiet da?
Ah, das hat einen im Forum. Naja, ohne Messwerte bringt mir das nichts.
Dann haben wir noch den NH. Wie alt die Dinger schon sind.
Der ist lauter, ne, das ist Temperatur. Lautstärke. Was sind die Lautstärke?
Ah, Lautstärke. Naja. So wirklich richtig leise ist das nettes Ding.
Der Test ist von 2013. Ich bin mal rettet, ja, aber ich bin nicht
angemeldet, ich lese halt. Aber Lüfter ist jetzt mal nicht so wichtig.
Also Lüfter rechnen wir noch mal. Keine Ahnung, 40 Euro oder so.
Bäm, guckt mal, da sind wir immer noch recht günstig dabei.
400, 550, 6 und 700. 750. Für 750 in Kombination mit meinen SSDs und
der 1080 Ti für ein wirklich absolut High End System ist doch als Upgrade in Ordnung.
Was, Thermal Riot True Spirits? Na, weniger als 30 DBA brauch ich net, aber
weniger als 36 hör ich schon was. Weniger als 30 brauch ich net, 30 hör
ich net. Aus dem Gehäuse schon mal gar net. Es ist halt so, dass DB generell ne ziemlich
kacke Einheit ist. So wie die halt skaliert, ne. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das quasi
linear steigen würde. Weniger glaube ich ganz gut.
Na, wie das steigt. Also 36 sind ne ganze Ecke lauter als 30.
Wenn das stimmt, ist das mein Lüfter. Es heißt nicht Sun, es heißt Sohne. Nur mal
so ein bisschen auf wichtig getan jetzt. Ja, den find ich ganz net. Hard for Lux auch
gute Seite für sowas. Danke für die Korrektur. Das ist gern geschehen. Sowas korrektier ich
immer gerne. Testresult Lautstärke. Aaron Jesus, guck mal was für Lüfter ich aktuell
hab. Ist fast der gleiche. Den nehm ich auch. Also den würd ich einfach nehmen für neun,
aber ich find die Idee jetzt langsam ganz gut, dass ich das alte einfach 1 zu 1 so intakt
lasse und in das andere Gehäuse umbaue und mir noch einen neuen Lüfter hol. Guck, von
Wege 21. Lull. The Game, von was habt ihr es da gerade? Was ist mit 60 Euro und von
was kriegst du mit 60 Euro? Redest du von Lüfter oder von Mainbots, die man sich kaufen
sollte zum übertakken oder? Ja Noctua Lüfter haben wir uns gerade angeguckt. Noctua find
ich ist ein super Hersteller und zudem tendier ich auch aktuell. Lohnt es sich von einem
6850k aufzurüsten auf einen 8700k? Ich bin nicht so fit was Intel CPU Bezeichnung anbelangt,
aber ich würd aus dem Bauch raus sagen, nee. Aber guck mal was das Ding hat. Nee, das lohnt
sich nicht. Das lohnt sich nicht. Es sei denn du hast zu viel Geld, aber dann ist ja nicht
die Frage ob es sich lohnt. Also ich find den Noctua trotzdem ganz gut. Egal, Lüfter
und das guck ich mir dann an. Ich schau jetzt, eine Sache gucken wir jetzt nochmal. Ist denn
irgendein Shop schon so mutig und sagt er ist lieferbar? Das kann ich mir aber nicht
vorstellen. Wir klinken uns den Kram gerade mal beim Minefactory zusammen. Einmal den
Kram hier please. Kein Montagenservice. Dann haben wir dann MSI was Terminator oder wie
heißt das Ding? Tomahawk.
RAM DDR4.
Irgendwie das billigste halt. Sind das 16? Sind das 16GB? Ah perfekt. Guck mal da ist
sogar der Noctua Lüfter noch drin. Wie hieß das Ding?
Oh, warum ist das so teuer? WTF? Warum ist das so teuer? Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Das
kostet bei anderen Shops 50 oder so. Warum ist das so teuer? Hä? Warte mal. Wir haben
doch vorhin geguckt, da war der doch viel günstiger. Äh, wat? Warte mal. Kann das sein, dass ich
einfach auf das falsche grade gucke? Der war doch vorher auch billiger. Der hat vorhin
halt irgendwie 53 gekostet oder so. Ich mach nochmal die Tabs auf. Das muss ich mir jetzt
mal angucken. Das ist aber echt teuer.
Oh mein Gott.
Kann es sein, dass sie den hier schlechter gehabt nicht haben?
Die haben den hier einfach nicht. Dann haben wir mal stellvertretend einen bisschen günstigeren rein,
um mal so zu gucken, was es am Ende ungefähr kosten würde, der ganze Spaß.
Also sind wir bei 740 Euro, damit kann ich leben. Da ist noch Luft nach unten,
weil ich habe jetzt einfach das genommen, was hier verfügbar ist, also den Kühler kriegen wir
auf jeden Fall günstiger und vielleicht auch ein anderer, weil das ist echt schon ganz happisch
für einen Kühler. Patrick, ich kann nicht den Pesslerer-Quali streamen, weil ich nur
6 MBit Upload habe. Das liegt also nicht daran, dass wenn wir da Grafikkarte können,
dann könnte ich da schon mehr machen, aber mehr geht halt auf Twitch nicht. So, das ist doch schon mal ein ganz gutes Setup.
Das steht und fällt jetzt damit, wann die CPU lieferbar ist. Du siehst, dass ich bei Unity Media bin, woher siehst du das?
Wo siehst du das?
6 MBit ist mit CPU ja nicht so viel anders. Ja, das GPU sieht ein bisschen schlechter aus, aber das macht es jetzt auch nicht aus.
Ich meine, das hier ist Standbild.
Ne, das ist gerade 1080.
Na, vielleicht mache ich ja dann Software-Encoding. Wenn da genug Wumms dabei ist, warum nicht, muss ich mal gucken.
Warum ich nicht die NVIDIA Software nehme, weil man mit der nicht so viele Sachen einstellen kann wie OBS.
Ob es stehen 8700 Übertakte, muss ich mal gucken. Würde das mit dem Mainboard überhaupt gehen?
Warum keine AMD-CPU? Ja, ich war ja quasi kurz davor, mir eine AMD-CPU zu kaufen. Aber Intel hat heute neue CPUs vorgestellt und ich finde,
die Kombination ist am besten zur Zeit. Vor allem, wenn man als hauptsächliche Sache hat Spielen gefolgt von dem hier.
Aber das hier ist das Wichtigste. Da ist Intel gerade wieder vorne. Es hat sogar einen One-Click-Overclock. Das ist doch auch nice.
Und wenn ich mir den dicken Lüfter draufpappe, dann bleibt das Ding auch kühl genug.
Jetzt eine Runde BF. Ne, jetzt eine Runde Abendessen. Ich habe jetzt eine Mini-Ecke Brot gefuttert gerade während dem Streben,
weil ich euch nicht vorschmatzen wollte. Ich gehe jetzt erstmal was essen. Reicht zum zocken nicht auch an eure E5, doch? Mit Sicherheit.
Ja, über Wasserkühlung habe ich auch nachgedacht, will ich nicht. Bin ich kein Fan von. Brauche ich auch nicht.
Also gibt es, Luftkühlung ist leise genug. In dem Fall. Also. Und ist auch billiger.
Über den Aldi PC. Ja, angeblich hat Aldi bzw. Medion schon PCs im Regal stehen mit den neuen Intel CPUs.
Also Aldi könnte mir ja mal 8700K verkaufen.
750 Euro sind nur Aufrüstkosten. Oder sagen wir mal 700. Eigentlich sind 680, weil ich könnte meinen alten CPU-Kühler ohne Probleme weiterverwenden.
Sag mal Patrick und Nils, was geht es bei euch gerade mit 5 Gigahertz und Aufpreis und sonst was? Könnt ihr mir das mal kurz erklären?
Aber Anderboy, nee, oder wer hat das gefragt? Andiversum, das ist nur Aufrüstpreis. Ach so, ob 8700 oder 8700K?
Die Frage stellt sich für mich überhaupt nicht. Ich kaufe mir einfach das beste.
Und dass der K mit offenen Multiplikator ist, habe ich auch keine Schmerzen mit. Ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Also das beste, was noch halbwegs sinnvoll ist. Bevor jetzt einer ankommt, Max, warum kaufst du dir dann keine Titan als Grafikkarte und sowas?
Aber ich finde das ok. 700 Euro quasi zum Aufrüsten, was aus einem relativ alten PC, der aber immer noch nicht schlecht ist, wieder den krassen High-End-Shit überhaupt macht.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen. Natürlich kann man das immer noch übertrieben. Man kann sich irgendwie eine noch teurere CPU kaufen.
Man kann sich noch teurere Grafikkarte kaufen, aber im Rahmen dessen, was gerade noch sinnvoll ist, ist es eigentlich das beste, was du dabei aktuell holen kannst.
Ja, das stimmt. Für Gaming lohnt sich das nicht, Patrick. Das ist wahr. Das braucht kein Mensch. Wahrscheinlich sind Games sogar langsamer.
Richtig. Das, was ich kaufe, ist für Gaming das beste, was es gibt.
Ja, das mit RAM-Preisen stimmt noch, aber ganz ehrlich, die 80 Euro mehr im Vergleich zu letztem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren oder so verkraftet ich auch noch.
Wie viel Standardgehäuse lüftet das Fractal F4? Ich glaube, ich guck da mal rein, ich hoffe, ich reiß jetzt hier nichts runter, weil ich hab mein Schreibtisch wieder hochgefahren.
Ich glaube, standardmäßig ist nur vorne einer drin gewesen. Ich muss mal kurz... Ah, ich kann nicht aufmachen, weil was vor der Tür steht. Gucken wir mal, ich glaube, standardmäßig war vorne nur einer drin.
Ja, ja, Tommy, klar, das reicht auch, Dicke. Was? Ah, nee. Okay, zwei Stück sind drin. Ah, ja klar, der hat hinten noch einen.
Ich hatte vergessen, dass das Netzteil, das Netzteil ist ja unten, ne? Ja, ja, genau. Passt.
Aber ich würde mir das R5 kaufen, wenn ich mir ein neues kaufe. Also quasi... Also quasi den da. Wenn ich mir schon einen neuen kaufe.
Kann man sich, weiß jemand, ob man sich von Geizhals irgendwo ne Mail schicken lassen kann, wenn ein Produkt bei einem Händler verfügbar wird.
Also sprich, sobald irgendein Shop den Prozessor auf verfügbar setzt, kann man sich dann benachrichtigen lassen.
Geht das irgendwo? Programmiere doch selbst, ja.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird noch ein paar Tage dauern. Vielleicht auch noch eher 1-2 Wochen, bis man das ordentlich bekommt.
Also aktuell hat es keiner lieferbar. Jetzt vorbestellen. Was denn das? Verfügbarkeit bestellt. Ach so, Sie haben das bestellt, okay.
19.10. Jetzt vorbestellen.
Ja, Patrick, das stimmt. Das ist nicht schwierig.
Kann Minefactory das nicht? Doch, bestimmt. Vielleicht hat es ja nicht Minefactory als erstes gelistet, sondern jemand anderes.
Was sind die PCs bei dir auf der Arbeit eigentlich annehmbar? Du meinst, ob man damit arbeiten kann?
Ja, wir haben nur noch Notebooks. Das machen wir doch jetzt einfach mal.
Das sind Notebooks. Als erstes programmiere ich keine 8 Stunden. Ich gucke mir eher an, was andere Leute programmiert haben.
Außerdem sind das Notebooks mit Dockingstation.
Raus, das da rausholen. Wir können jetzt hier sagen, zack.
Ja, das ist halt nicht sehr einheitlich.
Das ist nicht sehr einheitlich, wie die das beschreiben. Jetzt vorbestellen, bestellen, noch nicht bestellt.
Die Frage ist, ob dann, gucken wir uns das bei einem anderen PC mal an, ob da verfügbar dran steht.
Irgendwas, was halt verfügbar ist. Wir könnten uns aber die Hintergrundfarbe angucken.
Wir müssen die Hintergrundfarbe rauskriegen, weil das schwierig sein wird.
Woran macht das Ding fest, welche Farbe das hat?
Das hat auch keine CSS.
Doch, das geht mit CREP, mit CREP geht alles. Gut, HTML passen vielleicht nicht unbedingt, aber das ist eigentlich total einfach, wenn ich von dem DIV hier feststellen könnte, wann es grün ist.
Background Color kommt von Offer Delivery Time.
In dem Fall Offer Delivery Time.
Warum hat Offer Delivery Time einmal grün?
Offer Available, wo gibt es das?
Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ja klar.
Das ist natürlich nichts Available.
Eigentlich, doch, das ist dann wirklich einfach.
Im Prinzip ist das alles, was wir machen müssen.
Sobald hier was rauskommt, schicken wir uns eine Mail.
Das war es dann eigentlich.
Das war jetzt nicht die hohe Kunst hier, aber das wird reichen.
Kann man Colt sagen, dass es Quiet sein soll?
Das ist der Gewalt von Minus-S, nicht Minus-Q.
Wir können es einfacher machen.
Wobei wir haben kein Notify installiert.
So in der Richtung könnten wir das dann machen.
Sobald das dann verfügbar ist, kriegen wir eine Mail.
Was jetzt natürlich nicht funktioniert.
So könnte man das machen.
Ich habe geguckt, wie wir uns benachrichtigen lassen können,
sobald auf Guides Hals die neue Intel CPU da ist.
Das ist mir schon klar, dass ich das brauche.
Wir können uns noch eine Discord-Message schicken lassen.
Egal.
Fertig geguckt.
Also eine Sache, die ich jetzt kapiert habe, dass die Mainboards sich alle nicht sonderlich viel nehmen.
Dass Gigabyte nicht so der Fan von Optisch und Toslink anschlüsseln ist.
Dass ich ungefähr mit 700 Euro dabei bin, aus meinem immer noch ziemlich guten System wieder ein Top-Gaming-Highend-System zu machen.
Das beste Highend-Gaming-System, was man sich zurzeit so kaufen kann.
Und ich finde, dafür kann man 700 Euro auch mal investieren.
Ich hoffe, euch hat das extrem gefallen.
Wir machen jetzt los. Ich habe Hunger. Ich muss was essen.
Ich würde sagen, macht es gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017
Untertitel für funk, 2017